TWENTY SIXTH MEETING OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO ORDER MAN OF
SECRETARY SENATORS BATES. BATES
HERE MONNING. MONNING HERE RAFI
RAFI HERE WELL HERE WILL CURE
ATKINS HERE. FIVE THANK YOU- I
THINK WHAT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND DO BECAUSE WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE IN MULTIPLE
HEARINGS TODAY- I WILL TRYING
TO ESTABLISH A CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THEN WE'LL GO INTO THE TO
THE APPOINTEES SO IF I COULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO BILL REFERRALS.
ITEMS THREE THROUGH EIGHT WHICH
ARE STANDING COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS- ITEM NINE SELECT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS ITEM TEN
JOINT COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS
ARE ITEMS ELEVEN THROUGH
FOURTEEN SUBCOMMITTEE
RATIFICATIONS. AN ITEMS FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN FLOORS KNOWLEDGE
MINTS- OKAY MAKING SURE
EVERYBODY'S GOOD WITH THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BATES BATES
AYE MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH
ROTH I WILL WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND RIGHT BEFORE I INVITE OUR
FIRST APPOINTEE OF I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AINA. BECAUSE
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO WE WERE ABLE
ON THE FLOOR TO RECOGNIZE-
TRANSCRIBERS INTERPRETERS AND
STENOGRAPHERS AND SHE IS OUR
INCREDIBLE- REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THAT BODY AND- SERVICES EVERY
WEEK AT THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
WE JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HER
WHILE SHE'S HERE PUBLICLY. DID
YOU TYPE THAT OUT. EXTREMELY
SIGNIFICANT APPLAUSE BY THE
BODY. THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
LET ME GO AHEAD AND INVITE-
SAMANTHA MARIE UP- AS OUR FIRST
A POINTY OUT WELCOME MEMBER THE
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION AND-
WILL INVITE YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYBODY THAT'S HERE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO AND THEN GO RIGHT
INTO YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND
IT WILL GO RIGHT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESS HAMMER MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE
TO FIRST INTRODUCE MY FAMILY MY
HUSBAND JASON IS IN THE BACK.
AND NEXT TO HIM IS MY SON
WRITER HE SEVEN. HE'S GOT A TAN
AND MY DAUGHTER WELL LET SEIZE
FIVE SHOULD BE SIX NEXT MONTH.
IS THE BEST PART OF THESE
HEARINGS BY THE WAY THANK YOU
WELCOME. IN CARE SO MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA MARIE AND I'M
CURRENTLY THE VICE PRESIDENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION I AM THRILLED TO
SERVE THE STATE OF. I AM
THRILLED TO SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME
FOR POINTING ME TO THIS
POSITION. I FEEL IN MANY WAYS
THE MY CAREER TO THIS POINT HAS
ALMOST DELIBERATELY PREPARED ME
FOR THIS APPOINTMENT AND I'M
HONORED TO BE SITTING HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I HAVE NEARLY
TWO DECADES OF EXPERIENCE IN
CONSERVATION POLICY ANALYSIS
AND MANAGEMENT. WHERE I'VE
DIRECTED ACADEMIC OCEAN AND
WATER PROGRAMS AT SCRIPPS
INSTITUTION OF OCEANOGRAPHY.
OCEAN CONSERVANCY THE AUDUBON
SOCIETY AND MORE. I HAVE FISHED
RECREATIONALLY MY WHOLE LIFE
STARTING AT A YOUNG AGE AND
HAVE TAKEN GREAT PRIDE IN
SEEING MY KIDS CATCH THEIR
FIRST TITLE OF IT. FIRST CALICO
BASS FIRST BROKERS. IT'S BEEN
ESPECIALLY REWARDING TO
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THESE FIRST
WITH COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FISHERMEN WHO I'VE
GOTTEN TO KNOW OVER THE COURSE
OF MY CAREER. I GREW UP IN A
HUNTING AND- I'VE ALWAYS
MAINTAIN A STRONG CONNECTION
AND DEEP RESPECT FOR THE SPORTS
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE UNITED
STATES I VERY MUCH CREDIT MY
SMALL TOWN UPBRINGING AND TIME
SPENT ON THE RIVER WITH MY
CAREER TRAJECTORY. I UNDERSTAND
FIRSTHAND THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT HUNTERS AND FISHERMEN PLAY
IN THE ROLE OF CONSERVATION. MY
PRIORITY FOR THE COMMISSION IS
TO ENSURE THE LONG TERM
BIODIVERSITY AN ABUNDANCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES. ENDS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RICH HUMAN
INTERACTIONS AND ENJOYMENT. I
ALSO SEEK TO PROVIDE AN OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT AND INVITING
FORM FOR STAKEHOLDERS THE
PUBLIC AND COMMISSIONERS TO
SHARE AND DISCUSS IDEAS.
JOINTLY FIND COMMON GROUND AND
DEVELOP SOLUTIONS. I'M INSPIRED
BY THE NOTION OF IMPLYING MY
DIVERSE PROFESSIONAL AND
EXPERIENCE- BACKGROUND TO A
POSITION IN WHICH I CAN DROP
BOTH ON MY SUBSTANTIVE
KNOWLEDGE AND PRACTICAL
UNDERSTANDING TO BENEFIT THE
FISH WILDLIFE AND COMMUNITIES
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR EIGHT YEARS
I SAT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
FAITHFULLY ATTENDING OVER THAN
MONTHLY MEETINGS. IT'S AN HONOR
TO NOW FIND MYSELF BEHIND THE
DíAS CARRYING ON THE LEGACY OF
PAST COMMISSIONERS AND SERVING
TODAY WITH FOR TALENTED
COMMITTED AND RESPECTFUL
COMMISSIONERS WHOM I GREATLY
ADMIRE. HAVING WITNESSED THE
COMMISSION'S IMPACT ON FISH AND
WILDLIFE FIRSTHAND OVER THE
COURSE OF MANY YEARS I THOUGHT
THIS APPOINTMENT TO MAKE A
POSITIVE CONTRIBUTION ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
COMMITTED TO OUR STATE INVESTED
IN SUPPORTING THRIVING NATIVE
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT OUTDOOR ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION TODAY. VERY
MUCH- LET ME GO AHEAD AND START
WITH YOU SENATOR ROTH I KNOW
BOTH YOU AND MR MONNING MAY
HAVE TO LEAVE SO. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM AN EXTRAORDINARY
RESUME AND BACKGROUND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE- THERE MANY OTHER THINGS
YOU COULD DO AND WE'RE PLEASED
THAT YOU'RE SERVING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BE. HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTIONS- AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING YOUR
CONFIRMATION IF I'M STILL HERE.
IN THIS ROOM AT THE TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU SENATOR ROSS THANK
YOU SENATOR AND- JUST MAKE SURE
THE ROLE WILL BE LEFT OPEN IF
THAT COLLEAGUES HAVE TO STEP
AWAY AND GO ELSEWHERE SO. THEY
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY VOTE
WHETHER THEY ARE HERE NOT AT
THAT TIME. IT WITH RESPECT TO-
MY VICE CHAIR I'M GOING TO GO
TO SENATOR MINING IN THE DO YOU
DO YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE ALSO
YOU SHOULD BE AT OTHER THAN
HERE. SO AND NOW YOU SEE WHY HE
IS A VICE CHAIR. SENATOR MINING
I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU
ALSO ARE MY GREATEST PRIORITY.
THIS BUILDING BUT SERVING YOUR
INTERESTING WHO WILL HAVE TO GO
TO JAIL LACKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. YOUR INTERESTS ARE WELL
REPRESENTED- BUT WITH THAT ON A
SERIOUS NOTE I TWO ONE JUST HAD%
MY CONGRATULATIONS. MY
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO. TO SERVE IN
THIS CAPACITY WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY YOU
MIGHT JUST BE OF INTEREST TO
THE PANEL WE TALKED SOME ABOUT
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT SOME
EFFORTS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO.
CHANGE THAT IN HE OFFERED SOME
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE SON
INDENTURED SPECIES PROTECTION.
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND SHARING
THAT WITH THIS. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY- WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
TO HAVE OUR OWN CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT WHICH
MEANS THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL ON PROTECTED
SPECIES WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OFFER VERY STRONG PROTECTIONS
TO SPECIES HERE THAT FIND
THEMSELVES ON THE TRAJECTORY
TOWARDS EXTINCTION SO- WERE
WERE VERY LUCKY TO BE IN THAT
POSITION AND IN SOME IN SOME
WAYS THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT OFFERS EVEN MORE
PROTECTION IT DOES HAVE A
CLAUSE THAT SAYS- TAKE WILL BE.
MINIMIZED AND FULLY MITIGATED
FOR SPECIES THAT ARE LISTED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT AND FREQUENTLY ARE
OUR PIECE OF LEGISLATION TENDS
TO BE A LITTLE BIT LESS
POLITICIZED THAN THAT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
PROTECTIONS TO THE SPECIES THAT
NEEDED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. IT WILL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I DON'T
HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- COURTESY IN. FOR
SENATOR RAWSON ME I THINK I'M
GOOD FOR A WHILE SO THAT'S OKAY
IN HERE THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SORRY WE DIDN'T GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET ALTHOUGH
TALK TO ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND YOU GOT RAVE REVIEWS ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM. SO I THINK THE
GOVERNOR MADE THE RIGHT CHOICE
IN IN THIS IN THIS CASE.
FISHING DANCE ONLY HAVE ONE I
NEVER ASK A QUESTION THAT HAVE
AS PRIVATELY BUT WE DID MEET
PRIVATELY BUT YOU MENTIONED
BASS FISHING SO WHERE IS THE
BEST PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. BASS
FISHING I KNOW THE ANSWER I
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER. RATES SO THE BASS
FISHING THAT WE DID WAS NOT IN
CALIFORNIA SADLY BUT DO YOU
KNOW WHERE. WE WERE AND WE WERE
IN MEXICO OKAY YEAH WELL THE
BEST IS IN MY DISTRICT IF YOU
WANT TO BRING THE FAMILY COM.
LET THE HOST YOU ITS CASTAIC
LAKE RIGHT UP BY FIVE IN TODAY
BELIEVE THAT THE LARGEST BASS
IN THE WORLD IS IN. IN THAT
LAKE THANK YOU SENATOR WHERE IT
IS MORE LIKE A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND IN IN SPONSORSHIP
ADS IF YOU GET IT SO BRING-
FAMILY DOWN MAYBE AUGMENT YOUR-
YOU ONLY GET PER DIEM WAS NOT
VERY MUCH MONEY SO MAYBE WE CAN
AUGMENTED BY. HAVING YOUR
DAUGHTER YOUR SON CASH THAT
WORLD RECORD BASS THANK ANYWAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE- NICE.
THERE'S A LOT I COULD SAY. I
SENATOR BATES I WILL JUST BE-
TURN IT OVER TO YOU. I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO START WITH I'VE
GONE TO A CAMPUS IN WE'VE GOT
SOME GOOD FISH I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE WORD THOUGH BECAUSE MY
HUSBAND'S A FILTER PERSON BUT-
ANYWAY I HAVE A WONDERFUL
BACKGROUND WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION I WE DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE TO MEET. FACE TO FACE
BUT CERTAINLY A YEAR CIVIL
QUALIFIED AND YOU HAVE WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF THE
ONLINE SERVICES THAT YOU HAVE A
REAL PASSION FOR THIS
ASSIGNMENT I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS A AN
ISSUE THAT'S COME UP
LEGISLATIVELY. FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS ON THE PART OF A
LEGISLATOR WHO IS NOW RETIRED
BUT IT WAS THE EXTENSION OF
FISHING LICENSES FOR A YEAR
FROM THE DATE OF PURCHASE AND I
KNOW THAT'S BEEN A
RECOMMENDATION OUGHT TO THE
COMMISSION FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT THAT BECAUSE IT TO
THE- PROM THAT WE'RE IN WITH
REDUCTION IN. ACTUALLY THE
LICENSE BECAUSE- MANY OF THEM
DON'T LAST THE ENTIRE YEAR YOU
HAVE TO RE UP SO IT SEEMED TO
BE A- BETTER WAY TO DO IT BY.
REGULAR THEY LEGISLATION BY. ON
THAT WAS A- PLAN AT HIM FOR A
COUPLE YEARS. WHAT PAST COUPLE
YEARS. SO YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SENATOR BATES- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE FISH AND GAME
CODE IS WRITTEN WE ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE THE AUTORITY. TO
GET AWAY FROM THE CALENDAR
YEAR- LICENSES BUT THERE IS A
BILL- BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. THAT DOES PROPOSE THIS-
TWELVE MONTHS AT LICENSE-
LICENSE OVER A- ANNUAL CALENDAR
YEAR. AND WE HAVEN'T TAKEN A
FORMAL POSITION ON ITS I AM
AWARE THAT OTHER STATES HAVE
TRIED THE STRATEGY AND FOR
EXAMPLE IN ABOUT I BELIEVE
SALES WENT UP. 35% OR SO- IT
COULD BE A FIT FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT AGAIN WE HAVEN'T TAKEN A
POSITION ON IT I KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE SOME UP FRONT COSTS
POTENTIALLY RELATED TO-
INSTALLING NEW SOFTWARE SO YOU
CAN GET THE SYSTEM UP AND
RUNNING. AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AUTO RENEWAL PIECE IS
A IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT AS
WELL FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE
TWELVE MONTH CYCLE FOR FISHING
LICENSES BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WERE AWARE OF
BEEN. AND THINKING AND TRACKING
CLOSELY. LEGISLATOR THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR AND YOU WILL HAVE MY
FULL SUPPORT GRADUATIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR. THANK YOU-
I'M THRILLED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR APPOINT ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND- I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH SENATOR OFTEN.
RESERVE OR- MAIN ONLY WORK WITH
PRESS. I THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GRAY. BY THE WORK
THAT YOU DO I. WE ARE FORTUNATE
TO HAVE SO IN CALIFORNIA I ONLY
HAVE ONE QUESTION I WANTED TO
GET AN UPDATE FROM YOU. AS CO
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION'S
MARINE RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND
THE MASTER PLAN- IT HAS BEEN
UPDATED FOR MARINE LIFE
MANAGEMENT ACT. WHAT DO YOU
ENVISION AS THE NEXT STEPS ON
THAT. YES THANK YOU SENATOR SO
RIGHT NOW- THE MARINE LIFE
MANAGEMENT ACT MASTER PLAN
WHICH WAS ADOPTED BY THE
COMMISSION IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT'S A STANDING
AGENDA ITEM FOR THE MARINE
RESOURCES COMMITTEE THAT I CO
CHAIR. AND WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO AND TO
PRIORITIZE WHICH FISH IS ARE
REALLY NEEDED I HAVE OF
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS. DALY TRYING
TO DECIDE WHICH OF THE
FISHERIES THAT. THAT THAT WE
THAT WE MANAGE WHICH ONES
REALLY NEED ATTENTION WHETHER
THAT'S AN UPDATE TO THEIR
MANAGEMENT PLAN OR A NEW
FISHERY MANAGEMENT PLAN OR OR
SOMETHING SIMILAR WHICH NEEDED
FIRST AND THAT CAN BE BASED ON
STRESSORS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND YOU KNOW WANTING TO BE
REALLY ADOPTIVE IN TERMS OF
ACKNOWLEDGING CHANGING OCEAN-
TO DECIDE WHICH WE- PUT FORWARD
IN A WORK PLAN TO ADDRESS.
IMMEDIATELY. I DON'T HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE SO I WILL TURN TO
THE PUBLIC AND ASK. FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT. YOU ARE WELCOME TO
COME UP TO THE MIKE GIVE ME
YOUR NAME OF WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND VERY BRIEFLY- IT YOUR
POSITION. WELL IN THIS CASE
YOUR SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIRMAN OF
MEMBERS COMMITTEE BUT TOM
RADICAL THE SPORTFISHING
CONSERVANCY. I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE WORKING WITH SAMANTHA
FOR OVER A DECADE SHE'S
THOROUGH SHE'S RESPONSIBLE
SHE'S THE ADULT IN THE ROOM WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING WEARING A
NUMBER OF HATS IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY AND THOSE HATS
ARE FOR OCEANIA THE PEW
CHARITABLE TRUST THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE OFFICERS FOUNDATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA FISHINGGAME
AND MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS
ASSOCIATION CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR SERVING
SAMANTHA. THANK YOU. WELCOME
MADAM CHAIRMAN IS COMMITTEES MY
NAME IS BILL GAINES ALSO
WEARING A LOT OF HATS TODAY
FROM THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
COMMUNITY INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
WATERFALLS ASSOCIATION ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION
WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION.
CALIFORNIA BOWMAN HUNTER STATE
ARCHERY ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FOR
CONSERVATION ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN NAME
IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA JUST ONE
HAD TODAY BUT I WOULD SAY
QUICKLY IN ADDITION TO HER.
SKILLS OR KNOWLEDGE OR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ISSUES
SAMANTHA WAS ALSO ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL ORGANIZER'S OF OCEANS
DAY WHICH THIS YEAR IS MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH SO IF IT'S NOT ON
YOUR CALENDAR PLEASE PUT IT
THERE. AND WE'RE STRONG STRONG
SUPPORTERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO
HERE IN THE SOUTH TO CLEAN
SUPPORTIVE DISAPPOINTMENT-
BELIEVE SHE HAS THE SKILLS AND
EXPERTISE THAT'S NEEDED TO
BALANCE THE INTERESTS MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS. TO PROTECT THE
STATE'S PRICE BIODIVERSITY AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AND THINKING.
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
A COMMISSION MURRAY TO PLAYERS
HERE- FOR SOMEONE RECOGNIZED AT
MY FIRST PRIORITY IS AND ALWAYS
HAS BEEN SENATOR ATKINS SHE
NEEDS- TELL ME YOUR NAME I KNOW
YOUR NAME GEORGE OSBORNE SORRY
THAT'S A REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SPORTFISHING LEAGUE.
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER ON BEHALF
OF COMMISSION MURRAY I ALSO
SUBMITTED A LETTER ON BEHALF OF
NOT A CLIENT- BUT SOMEONE WHO
IS GREAT BACKGROUND WITH
COMMISSIONER MURRAY AND IT'S
THE AMERICAN SPORTFISHING
ASSOCIATION. THE COMMISSION
MARINE I FIRST BECAME
ACQUAINTED. FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
DURING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MARINE LIFE PROTECTION ACT
WE WERE ON OPPOSITE SIDES. WE
DID GREAT BATTLE. IN THE
EVENING WADE GATHER AND THE B.
COLLEGIAL AND DURING THAT
ENTIRE PROCESS SHE WAS
PROFESSIONAL DID HER JOB
REPRESENTED HER SIDE VERY
PROFESSIONALLY SHE'S
TRANSPARENT. SHE SMART SHE HAS
A GREAT BACKGROUND IN WHAT
SHE'S BEEN ASKED TO DO AND
VOLUNTEER TO DO ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNOR AND WE APPRECIATE
HER SERVICE AND I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER- I
THINK THAT SHE'S GOING TO BE A
LEADER ON A FISHING GAME
COMMISSION BECAUSE OF HER.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS I
JUST MENTIONED BUT ESPECIALLY
HER BACKGROUND AND HER
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FISHERIES WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
WE'RE PROUD TO- AM PLEASED TO
OFFER OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OKAY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
OPPOSITION. YOUR FAMILY THAT'S
A GOOD SIGN. THEY CAME ALL THIS
WAY- SENATOR ROTH I BELIEVE YOU
WANTED TO MOVE THE CONFIRMATION
MADAM SECRETARY SENATORS BATES
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH FIVE WILL WILK AYE
AND FIVE CONSISTING GRADUATIONS.
UNANIMOUS IS SOMEONE. HE WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT AND INVITE MARCO.
MAGIC YOU'RE GONNA SAY YOUR
LAST NAME FOR ME SAY IT AGAIN
ME TOO. OUR PEOPLE GET THAT
WRONG OFTENTIMES BEACH WILL
WELCOME- THE DEPUTY DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY OCT. A HUGE JOB
IN A HUGE TASK AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO WELCOME YOU HERE
TODAY AND I'M ALSO OFFER YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE
ANYONE THAT'S HERE TO SUPPORT
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE AND THEN
GO RIGHT INTO YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS AND STATEMENT AND
WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO THE
CONVERSATION WITH- THE RULES
COMMITTEE WELCOME AND THANK
YOU. IN ADDITION TO MY WIFE FOR
ANNIKA MEETS MY MOTHER AND
FATHER IN LAW. ONE IN THE MAIL
THE RUMOR IS MY MOM AND DAD
MERE SEVEN VESNA MEECH MY
BROTHER IN LAW AND SISTER IN
LAW JOHN INTERESTING REMEMBER
AS MY SISTER IN LAW AND BROTHER
AND JORDAN AND NICKI MINAJ. WOW
THAT'S A WHOLE GANG IS HERE.
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE- LET US
WELCOME YOU TO THE STATE
CAPITOL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS I AM
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF MY APPOINTMENT
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL I'M HUMBLED
BY THE APPOINTMENT BY THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND SECRETARY
DOLLY AT TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO
AGO I ARRIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES AS A REFUGEE FLEEING A
WAR TORN COUNTRY I SPOKE NO
ENGLISH AND MY FAMILY HAD
LITTLE TO OUR NAMES BEYOND THE
CLOTHES ON OUR BACKS AND THE
VERY FEW PERSONAL BELONGINGS
THAT WE COULD CRAM IN OUR
SUITCASES. MY PARENTS
SACRIFICED EVERYTHING SO THAT
MY BROTHERS AND I COULD HAVE A
BETTER LIFE AND A CHANCE AT A
FUTURE THIS IS WHY A THEY WERE
RELENTLESS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE TOOK EVERY ADVANTAGE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE TO US BY THIS
BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY I SHARE THIS
WITH YOU BECAUSE MY CHARACTER
IS SHAPED BY MY EXPERIENCES AND
MY COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
IS ROOTED IN THE IDEA THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN AND MUST LOOK TO
BUILD AN EQUITABLE JUST AND
TOLERANT SOCIETY. TOGETHER WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS AND
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS WE CAN
BUILD A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL OUR JOB AS GOVERNMENT IS
NOT ONLY O LEFT THOSE WHO'VE
BEEN MARGINALIZED BUT TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE
TO LIVE HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE
LIVES. I HOPE TO EARN YOUR
TRUST AND VOTE TODAY I DON'T
PRETEND TO BE PERFECT AND I
KNOW I WILL HAVE CHALLENGES IN
THIS ROLE HOWEVER EVERY DAY
THAT I SERVE IN THIS POSITION I
HOPE TO SERVE YOU AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
RESPECT DIGNITY AND HONESTY.
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IS JUST A SMALL WAY
I CAN GIVE BACK TO A COUNTRY IN
A STATE THAT TOOK A CHANCE ON
ME AND MY FAMILY. IT'S MY HOPE
THAT IN THE NEXT TWENTY TWO
YEARS PERHAPS A CHILD IN THE
MIGRANT SHELTERS. IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE OUR
WHO ARE SEEKING A SOUND WILL
COME BEFORE THIS VERY COMMITTEE
FOR CONFIRMATION.
PREPOSITIONING GOVERNMENT OR
PERHAPS BE AT THE DíAS A
SENATORS. DESPITE THE HORRIFIC
JOURNEY THAT MANY HAVE TO TAKE
HIM COME TO THIS COUNTRY. HAVE
A BRIGHT FUTURE AHEAD OF THEM
BECAUSE HERE ARE DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH. I'M A TESTAMENT
OF THAT AND THAT'S THE FOUNDING
PROMISE OF THIS STATE AND THIS
COUNTRY. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. NINE
AGAIN WELCOME. TO ARE YOUR
FAMILY. LET ME START WITH YOU
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN MISTER MEETS THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR SERVICE TODAY AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS
APPOINTMENT ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME YOUR FAMILY FOR NOT
ONLY BEING HERE BUT FOR THEIR
SUPPORT. OF YEAR. AMAZING
SUCCESS IN IN RESUME I
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I
APPRECIATED THE- BROAD RANGE
AND SHARING SOME OF THE-
CHALLENGES THAT. YOUR FAMILY
SUCCESSFULLY INJURED IN IN OVER
CAME- WE TALKED SOME ABOUT THE
CORONA VIRUS- IT'S IN OUR
HEADLINES IN OUR MINDS I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN IN A KEY POSITION
OF TRYING TO COORDINATE
RESPONSE IN CALIFORNIA. MAYBE
REAL TIME SHARE WITH THIS KIND
OF PUT SOME OF THE EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN HOW YOU'RE WORKING WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITIES- AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
I THINK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH ME YESTERDAY I
KNOW THAT THE NOVEL CORONAVIRUS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S TOP OF
EVERYBODY'S MIND SO. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE SPENT A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME THINKING AND
WORKING ON SO ET ME WALK YOU
THROUGH WHAT WE'VE DONE TODAY
AND WHAT WE KNOW AS OF THIS
MORNING. FIRST THE SPREAD
WITHIN CALIFORNIA WE CURRENTLY
HAVE EIGHT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE OF ALL RETURN
FROM THIS. FROM CHINA- WE HAVE
BEEN PRO ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
OUR LOCAL COUNTERPARTS. BOTH AT
THE COUNTY AND CITY LEVEL AS
WELL AS OUR EALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. TO PREPARE THEM FOR
THIS EVENT. UNLIKE MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM IS UNBELIEVABLY
IMPRESSIVE. AND I AM. CONFIDENT
THAT SHOULD THIS VIRUS SPREAD
ANY FURTHER BEYOND- WHAT IT HAS
TO DATE. THAT WE ARE
UNBELIEVABLY. TO RESPONSE I'LL
SAY WITH THAT. WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT THIS FROM A ONE
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE SO. YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES LEADING THIS
EFFORT. IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES A
STORY. THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE CALLOW YES
PARTNERS. AND THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS ARE THERE- AND THAT
OUR- OUR- HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
PARTNERS ARE THERE. RECENTLY
WE'VE BEEN CONVENING WITH. OUR
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES WE
SEND OUT FACT SHEETS TO SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE'VE DONE
THE SAME FOR PRESCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE FACILITIES. AS WELL
AS UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES-
WE'VE BEEN IN CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. I LEAD A CALL EVERY
MORNING WITH MY COLLEAGUES WITH
THE CDC THE ASPER AND THE HHS.
AND WE ARE IN COORDINATION WITH
ALL OF THE OTHER ENTITIES OF
STATE GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE RESPONDING THIS
REALISTICALLY- I THINK THIS IS
INVOLVING SITUATION- THAT IS
CHANGING QUITE RAPIDLY. BUT I
THINK IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
DEFINITELY PREPARED WE'VE BEEN
TESTED WITH H. ONE AND ONE AND
SARS- BUT I THINK WE ARE READY
TO TAKE THIS ON. THANK YOU.
IRIS OTHER MEMBERS MAY HAVE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON THAT BUT
I WANT TO JUST TEST ANOTHER
QUESTION WE DISCUSSED.
POTENTIAL PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS
OF THE PUBLIC CHARGE ANA
DECLARATIONS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- FOCUSED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS BUT- OUR
CONCERN ABOUT. UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN US CITIZENS NOT FULLY
REALIZING BENEFITS THEY MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR HOW HOW ARE YOU
AND YOUR DEPARTMENT DEALING
WITH THAT SENATOR THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION AGAIN AND
THIS IS TOP OF MY MIND WITH
THAT- WITH THE FINALIZATION OF
THE FEDERAL RULE ON MONDAY.
THERE'S TWO PIECES TO THIS
FIRST I THINK THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE UNBELIEVABLY
VULNERABLE- AND THEY ARE SCARED
IN TERMS OF WHAT BENEFITS THEY
MIGHT WANT TO PARTAKE IN A AND
WHAT IMPACT THAT MIGHT HAVE ON
THEIR STATUS WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES. WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
REALLY LOOKED AT HOW WE
ORGANIZE COLLECTIVELY IS ONE
GOVERNMENT TO THINK ABOUT OUR
MESSAGING SO IT'S NOT
BIFURCATED AND DIFFERENT WHEN
IT COMES OUT OF SACRAMENTO- AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY I THINK THE
COMMUNITY THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS
THE STATE DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT TO HEAR FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT THEY WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THEY TRUST AND VALUE. AND
SO WE'VE BUILT COALITIONS
WITHIN IT WITH ORGANIZATIONS
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
EMPOWER THEM WITH THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION SO THAT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS THE CHALLENGE SENATOR
HERE IS NOT OVER COMMITTING IN
TELLING SOMEBODY THAT
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE OKAY
BUT REASSURING THEM THAT HERE
IS THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE AND BEING ABLE TO
NAVIGATE AND THROUGH THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE SENT OUT
TO ALL YOUR OFFICES FACT SHEETS
IN BOTH ENGLISH AND SPANISH
ABOUT THIS TOPIC WE ALSO WORKED
WITH OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES TO
SEND OUT INFORMATION TO WORK
ACT IT COUNTERPARTS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ARE ADMINISTERED.
BY OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION AND SO OUR HOPE IS
BY ENGAGING LOCAL COUNTERPARTS
IN ORDER TO SPREAD THE
INFORMATION AND GIVE THE
INFORMATION TO THEM IN A WAY
THAT'S DIGESTIBLE
UNDERSTANDABLE AS A WAY THAT
WE'RE GONNA I. BUT A IS
SOMETHING THAT'S OF SICK.
CONCERN TO ME AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION TO. THANK YOU
AND AS YOU MENTION AS WE
DISCUSSED YESTERDAY THE
CHALLENGE. IS PROVIDING
ACCURATE INFORMATION SO WE
DON'T. CAN MISLEAD PEOPLE IN A
MANNER THAT CAN HAVE AN ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCE BUT YOU HAVE
FAMILIES WITH CITIZEN CHILDREN.
MAYBE A GREEN CARD LEGAL
IMMIGRANT PARENT MAY BE A
PARENT AND IS IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO ADJUST STATUS- IN AS
A FAMILY THEY'RE HAVING TO
NAVIGATE- A LABYRINTH OF
DIFFERENT. REGULATIONS BUT
NUTRITION PROGRAMS THAT US
CITIZEN CHILDREN ARE FULLY
ELIGIBLE FOR IN MANY IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN ARE. MAYBE JUST A
FINAL COMMENT ON HOW IN YOUR
WORK WHEN THE COUNTIES AND
AGENCIES. WE DON'T OVER PROMISE
BUT WE ALSO WORK TO MAKE SURE
THOSE THAT ARE INDEED LEGAL
LEGALLY ELIGIBLE BENEFICIARIES-
DON'T MISS OUT ON WHAT CAN HELP
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR
BROADER COMMUNITIES YEAH I
THINK WE HAVE TO WALK A VERY
FINE BALANCE- WITH PROVIDING
INFORMATION THAT'S ACCURATE BUT
NOT OVER. OVER REASSURING AND
SO I THINK PART OF IT IS BEING
ABLE TO BE NIMBLE AND ADJUSTING
OUR MESSAGING AS WE BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CONCERNS OF
THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND ARE AND
I THINK ALSO LOOKING AT OUR
DATA IN CASE SO IT'S AND THE
TRENDS THAT ARE HAPPENING
WITHIN THE DATA- I THINK THAT
WE HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT TO
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS AS WELL AS
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO BE. TRUE
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT AND IN
REAL TIME ADJUSTER MESSAGING
SHOULD WE NEED TO ADJUSTED- I
THINK WE HAVE TO BALANCE THIS
NOTION OF OVER PROMISING TO
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO IS S. TELLING
SOMEBODY THAT THEY ARE OKAY TO
RECEIVE BENEFITS THEM RECEIVING
BENEFITS AND THEN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT DEEMING
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR CITIZENSHI
AND WE HAVE WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL IN TERMS OF HOW WE DRAW
THE LINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH I'M
GONNA THANK YOU. THAT APPROACH
ACTUALLY- I HAVE NO WELL I HAVE
NO QUESTIONS RESPECTFULLY
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. AT
SOME POINT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
AS TO WHETHER. WE'RE GOING TO
SURVIVE THE CHANGES TO THE MCO
TAX IN THE PROPOSED- PROGRAM
CHANGES- HAVING TO DO WITH
BLOCK GRANTS AND ARE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM BUT I'LL SAVE THAT FOR
ANOTHER TIME AND WOULD GET
HERE. WE'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE
YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME SENATOR THANK
YOU VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THOROUGHLY ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATION YESTERDAY BY
THE WAY I THINK YOU HAVE GREAT
TASTE AND TIES. I THINK SOME
AGO I THINK IT WILL BRING YOU
WITH ME- AND I REALLY ENJOYED
YOU EDUCATED ME ON THE WHOLE
CORONA VIRUS THING BECAUSE
LET'S FACE IT. WHERE THIS
NEWSPAPERS RADIO TV THEY'RE
THERE TO SELL ADVERTISING SPACE
I KNOW THEY'RE SCARING US AND
AS YOU KNOW I'VE GOT A FRIEND
RIGHT NOW WHO'S IN A FEDERAL
FACILITY IN OMAHA BECAUSE HE
WAS HIM AS MY FROM THE DIAMOND
PRINCESS CRUISE AND- HOW DID
THIS. TEN DAY CRUISE FOURTEEN
DAYS SITTING. IN YOUR ROOM A ON
A CRUISE SHIP. AND THEN YOU
THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE
GOING TO GO HOME IN THE SAID
NOPE YOU YOU TEST FOR
CORONAVIRUS NOW HE'S IN OMAHA
AND THEY KEEP SAYING HE'S GONNA
GO HOME AND ANY HE'S BEEN THERE
FOR EVER- SO THAT WAS GOOD. MY
DAD I DON'T NEED TO GO TO
STATUS I KNOW YOU KNOW THEM
THAT I WANT TALK ABOUT FOSTER
USE. OF IN MY DISTRICT ONE OUT
OF EVERY THREE FOSTER YOUTH
RESIDE IN MY DISTRICT. AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE STATS IS IN
ABJECT FAILURE AT AS A PROGRAM
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT SO I'M
GONNA MAKE A KIND OF BROAD BASE
AND YOU TAKE IT ANYWAY YOU WANT
TO GO. I'M INTERESTED IN THAT
THE COORDINATION OF SERVICES A
PARTICULARLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEN WHAT
SPECIFIC STEPS IS AGENCY LOOK
AT DOING IN TERMS EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND I AM GRATEFUL
FOR YOU TO TAKING THE TIME
YESTERDAY TO MEET WITH ME. I
WILL SAY THAT I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THESE YOUTH AND CHILDREN
ARE IN OUR CUSTODY IN THERE ARE
KIDS. AND I THINK THAT CULTURE
IN THAT MENTALITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THIS PERSON'S CATER THAT
DEPARTMENTS KID THERE ARE
COLLECTIVE AND WE HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM. I THINK
WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM EFFORT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I THINK
IT'S PART OF A CULTURE CHANGE
BOTH AT THE STATE LEVEL AND THE
COUNTY LEVEL TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY. ABOUT HOW WE TAKE
CARE OF THESE KIDS. AND
PRIMARILY WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
THESE CHILDREN IN CONGREGATE
CARE SETTINGS THAT DO NOT YOUR
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT IN
FACT THEY ARE. THAT THEY'RE NOT
THE RIGHT PLACE TO BE PUTTING
THEM AND SO PART OF CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM WAS TO SAY. HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT WE PLACE
THESE CHILDREN. IN FAMILY
SETTINGS WHERE THEY CAN THRIVE
AND BE SUCCESSFUL. AND SO I AM
REALLY HAPPY ABOUT THE
TRANSITION THAT WE'VE MADE WITH
REGARDS TO C. C. R. I THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON THAT FRONT. I THINK IN
ORDER FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
THESE KIDS HAVE SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES BOTH WHETHER IT'S THE-
MATTER. A SIDE. I WE OUGHT NEED
ENSURE THE STRIP. OR THE END.
WHO TAKING. THEM HAVE
APPROPRIATE TO ASSISTANCE.
SUPPORT THEM. WELL IT IN THE
ALL OF THEM HAS A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CAL. AND THE PARENT
KNOWS TO TURN TO OUR HOW TO
DEAL WITH IT. THE TYPE OF
THINGS THAT WE TO BE WORKING ON
IT ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THESE
ARE SUCCESSFUL. I AM PRETTY
COMP THAT OR CALL. HAS NEEDLE.
DO I. THAT WE- DON'T. OUT I
THINK GOT LOTS MORE WORK DO AND
POP OF IT IS S. S. COMING TO.
AND BREAKING TO. THIS I THINK
THAT. SOME OF THE HIGH NEEDS IT
SO AB TWO. EIGHT THE- PAST.
LAST I'D- REALLY. IT ON IF.
ABOUT HOW. BRING TO. A SYSTEM
OF CARE FOR THESE CHILDREN NOT
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS BUT ONE SYSTEM
WHETHER THEY'RE GETTING
SERVICES FROM MEDICAID OR THE
REGIONAL CENTER SPORTS. ED THAT
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THIS IS THE
KID. AND HERE THE KIDS NEEDS
AND WE'RE WRAPPING OURSELVES
AROUND THOSE NEEDS- AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND OTHER
COLLEAGUES. I THINK WE ARE ARE
NOW MEASURING OUR SUCCESS WITH
REGARDS TO SEIZE HERE THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. BUT I'M REALLY PROUD OF
WHERE WE'VE COME TODAY. EIGHTY
MORE WE CAN DO ON ON THE
EDUCATIONAL SIDE OF IT. YEAH I
MEAN I THINK PART OF IT IS OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS PART
OF THIS TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
WORK WE BROUGHT THEM INTO OUR-
INTO OUR- A FULL THEN. ARE
REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW WE-
ALIGN BOTH THE HEALTH SIDE IN
THE EDUCATION SIDE BECAUSE- IF
YOU SEND A KID TO SCHOOL AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
NUTRITION OR THE- ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS. YOU KNOW THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES ARE NOT
GONNA BE THERE SIMILARLY. TO
HEALTH OUTCOMES I MEAN WE CAN
GIVE SOMEBODY HEALTH INSURANCE
BUT IF THEY DON'T HAVE FOOD ON
THE TABLE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
HOUSING IF THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE THE SAME
OUTCOMES AND SO I THINK PART OF
IT IS MAKING SURE THAT WERE
SPEAKING AS ONE SYSTEM. AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT AND I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
MAKE SOME COULD PRETTY STRONG
PROGRESS IN THE COMING MONTHS
AND YEARS. GREAT THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT LOOKING FOR TO
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MISTER BEACH WE HAD A WONDERFUL
CONVERSATION JUST EARLIER IN
THE DAY AND I WILL SHARE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES. IN THOSE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT NIGHT I'M GOING
TO TEACH YOU DID YOU BRING ALL
YOUR FAMILY THINKING THERE
MIGHT BE SOME PEOPLE CLOSING
YOU BECAUSE- I'M- THIS IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPRESSIVE.
INTERVIEWS THAT I'VE HAD IN
PROBABLY BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF
IN MY DAILY WORK HAVING BEEN A
SOCIAL WORKER AND- UNDER-
CERTAINLY THE JURISDICTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND-
HUMAN SERVICES MANY YEARS AGO.
THERE WASN'T A QUESTION THAT I
COULD ASK MR MEETS THAT HE
DIDN'T HAVE A VERY IN DEPTH
ANSWER TO AND THAT IS
IMPRESSIVE. HOW WE HAVE THE
CORONA VIRUS ISSUE- YET ORANGE
COUNTY ALL RIGHT IT IS UNDER
LITIGATION SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO THERE BUT- HE ANSWERED
EVERY. SINGLE QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. HE ALSO DISPELLED ANY-
RUMORS THAT WE ARE NOT
COORDINATING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BOB THAT IS VERY
VERY CLOSELY COORDINATED AND
NOW HE IS. HAVING WEEKLY
BRIEFINGS WITH THOSE OF US WHO
HAPPEN TO HAVE. ALL THOSE
SITUATIONS IN OUR DISTRICTS SO-
NOT A SINGLE QUESTION I TALKED
ABOUT THIS FUNDING. ALL THAT
COUNTY BELIEVE FOR WHERE THAT'S
GOING ANY IMMEDIATELY TOLD ME
HOW THEY'LL BE APPROACHING
THAT. SO I'VE ANSWERED ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT I GAVE YOU THAT
YOU GAVE ME THE ANSWERS TO.
MAKE IT CLEAR. SO I DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL THAT ON WE ARE
SO FORTUNATE THAT YOU CAME TO
OUR COUNTRY THAT YOUR FAMILY
CAME TO OUR COUNTRY AND YOU
WERE MAKING SUCH AN INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTION. IN THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ARENA OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES IS THE
FOUNDATION TO A STRONG
DEMOCRACY WHEN WE HAVE. STRONG
PEOPLE HERE- WORKING WITH A
FULL THANK YOU AND ARE YOU WILL
HAVE. MY 2100% OF SUPPORT OF
YOUR CONFIRMATION SENATE OCCAM.
THANK YOU. I'M I WANT TO START
BY SAYING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP RECENTLY ON AND GETTING
NEEDED SUPPLIES TO UCSD- I
THINK IT TURNED OUT THEY DIDN'T
QUITE NEED WHAT WE THOUGHT THEY
DID. DON'T HOLD THAT AGAINST ME
WHEN I CALL THE ALL. TIME AND
SAY I NEED SOMETHING BECAUSE-
I'M BLAMING THEM FOR THAT. I
TOLD THEM DON'T ASK ME FIRST
OFF BECAUSE IF YOU DO YOU WILL
GET WHAT YOU NEED- SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU KNOW. BUT I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT I DID WANT TO ASK- SORT OF
ALONG THE LINES- YOU KNOW WE
HAD AN OUTBREAK OF HEPATITIS A
IN SAN DIEGO. A FEW YEARS AGO
AND BASED ON A STATE AUDIT AND-
LEGISLATURE REFORMS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE WE SEEN AN
IMPACT ON THAT AND I'LL MAKE
THE QUESTION A LITTLE BIT
BROADER BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT
THE CURRENT. SITUATION WITH
CORNER VIRUS. IT WE WORK
THROUGH OUR PARTNERS THE
COUNTIES I JUST WOULD LOVE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE OF EACH TIME
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
HOWEVER WE WORK IN BETTER AND
BETTER WITH THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE PARTNERS WE ARE
A BIG STATE. AND IT SEEMS A
LITTLE FRIGHTENING TO ME THAT
WE MIGHT HAVE TO COUNT ON FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ARE. WORKING
WITH THE STATE DO YOU SEE AREAS
WHERE WE NEED TO IMPROVE OUR
SENATOR IN TERMS OF YOUR
QUESTION AROUND THAT PARTICULAR
SITUATION ON THE HEPATITIS
OUTBREAK I THINK I'M THAT DID
NOT GO OUT WELL AND I THINK WE
LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS WITH
REGARDS TO OUR ROLE AS A STATE
AND OUR COUNTY PARTNERSHIP AND
I THINK THAT. WHAT I WILL SAY
THERE IS THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO BE MUCH MORE PROACTIVE IN
THERE OKAY INSTANCES WHERE WE
MIGHT DISAGREE WITH THAT
PARTICULAR COUNTY IN TERMS OF
APPROACH AND THAT'S OKAY. I
THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE AN HONEST
AND FRANK CONVERSATION AND WE
NEED TO BE OPEN ABOUT IT AND- I
THINK THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN FROM THESE INSTANCE SAYS.
EVERY SINGLE SCENARIO IS
DIFFERENT AND EVERY RESPONSE
YIELDS A DIFFERENT RESPONSE AND
I THINK PART OF IT IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT OUR ROLES
AND AUTHORITIES ARE AND IN SOME
INSTANCES A REQUIRE US GOING IN
AND SAYING WE MIGHT HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT AND WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE- ELEVATE
THAT IN THE STATE TAKING A MORE
PROMINENT ROLE IN A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY- I. THINK THAT WE
LEARNED A LOT FROM THAT AUDIT
FINDING IN TERMS OF SAN DIEGO
IN PARTICULAR. AND I THINK THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS DOING A LOT
IN ORDER TO THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO BE MORE REALISTICALLY
RESPONSE SOME OF THESE PIECES
IT'S NOT ALTHOUGH EVERY CAN IN
A BE FOR. BRUCE TO BE SPENT
THERE ARE PLUS THAT WE HAVE OUR
JOB. TO I'M SO. I HOPE I
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION BUT I
THINK THERE'S A LOT THAT WE
LEARNED FROM THAT EXPERIENCE IN
SAN DIEGO. IN IT I MEAN I THINK
FOR ME AND PROBABLY FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ALL OVER THE STATE
WHEN THERE IS A SITUATION LIKE
THAT. AND WE MAY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW ARE COUNTY MIGHT BE
ACTING WE'RE NOT I'M NOT A
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT BY ANY
STRETCH. YOU KNOW. I THINK I
WANT TO KNOW WHEN CAN THE STATE
STEP IN AND TAKE A OVER RIDE-
AND AS LONG AS YOU HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE YOU. FEEL LIKE YOU
GET THE ABILITY TO EVALUATE A
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES. MAKE A
DETERMINATION AND DECIDE.
WHETHER IT IS IN THE OVER
ARCHING- INTEREST FOR STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH. FOR THE STATE TO
ACTUALLY. STEP IN AND DO WE
HAVE REALLY THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT. I THINK WE DO AND I THINK
THAT IT WILL ALWAYS DEPEND ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCE LET ME PUT IT
THAT WAY- AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN BUILD CONSENSUS
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS THAT'S
THE- THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO
STRIVE FOR. FIRST AND FOREMOST
BUT I THINK IF THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN AND AT LEAST IN
THE PUBLIC CAL SPACE AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CONTROL
PARTICULARLY. THEIR THINGS
ACTIONS THAT WE CAN TAKE AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT. WE ARE AT LEAST
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF INDIVIDUALS IN
EITHER THAT COMMUNITY OR IN THE
BROADER COMMUNITY CONTEXT.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THAT GIVES ME A SENSE OF WELL
BEING THAT. YOU WANT TO WORK
WITH THE PARTNERS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME YOU'RE PREPARED TO DO
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. BOB AND
YOU DONE THAT AGAIN GET. ON
MULTIPLE ISSUES TERMS NEED IN
THE COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY. I
WILL SAY IN. WE NEEDED STATE
ASSISTANCE- ON AN ISSUE THAT
WAS A REALLY HOURS. TECHNICALLY
SPEAKING ARE LEGALLY SPEAKING
BUT WE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
VISITING THE SHELTER I THINK IT
MEANT. A GREAT DEAL TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE- SO MY THANKS TO YOU FOR
DOING THAT THANK YOU IT'S OUR
COMMUNITY- I WE DON'T. MAY I
WELL IT WITH THE A SIDE WE
DON'T ALL SIT ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
HOMELESS. PROPOSE ONE PLANNED-
ANYTHING AND I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN SOME CONVERSATION ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. I'D LOVE TO
GET A LITTLE BIT OF YOUR VISION
ON WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AND HOW
YOU'RE- UNDERTAKING- THE
CONVERSATION AS WE COME
TOGETHER TO TRY TO. SUPPORT THE
RESOURCES BUT MAKE SURE. THAT I
THEY WILL BE USED EFFECTIVELY
WORKING WITH THOSE SAME
PARTNERS IN MANY CASES AND
OTHERS. SO I THINK SENATOR IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
AT LEAST THE PAST TWO YEARS
WE'VE MADE SOME SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. I THINK IT IS
STILL A CRISIS AND I THINK IT
JUST POINTS TO. THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT ON THIS BY
DEDICATING HIS ENTIRE STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS TO THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC- IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE YOU- WE'RE LOOKING
TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA ACCESS
TO HOUSING SERVICES FUND WITH
THE IDEA THAT WE INVEST SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND BUILD ON TOP OF THAT WITH
PHILANTHROPIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR DOLLARS- I THINK. WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS A LOOK AT
HOW WE DISRUPT THIS ISSUE. AND
PERHAPS A DIFFERENT WAY THAT WE
HAVE TODAY. AND IN MY
CONVERSATION CENTER BATES IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IT COMES
DOWN TO THE CATERPILLAR DE THAT.
THE OUTCOMES WANT TO BE ABLE TO
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO PARTICULAR
OUTCOMES THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
WITH THESE DOLLARS TEN PART OF
IT TOO IS THAT- PUBLISHED IT
DOES NOT. ISOLATED TO ONE
PARTICULAR. AREA OF WHETHER
THAT'S A GEOGRAPHIC CITY OR CAN
BE. FACT MOVES ACROSS CAP LINES
ANY. SAYS SO. THERE NOT ALL THE
TRYING PRESENT TO. IS LOOK AT
HOW DO WE JUST THIS PROCESS. IN
ORDER PRIVATE OUT MEANS THE
ONLY OTHER THING I WAS IS THAT
GOV CANNOT SOLVE THE ALONE. IN
PART OF THE IDEA BE. REALLY
LOOK AT CREE THIS FIND. AND
ALLOWING PHILANTHROPY AND
PRIVATE SECTOR TO COME TO THE
TABLE IS TO REALLY CREATIVELY
THINK ABOUT HOW WE YES
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. TO TRY
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEMFOR THE
NEIGHBORS THAT WE WALK BY I
MEAN THIS AFTERNOON ON MY WAY
INTO THE CAPITAL. I DID WALK BY
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SITTING ON THE STREET. AND I
THINK WE MUST DO BETTER FOR
THEM WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE NOT IN SHOULD ONLY ENSURE.
THAT WE GIVE THEM HOUSING BUT
THAT WE WRAP THEM AROUND WITH
THE APPROPRIATE SERVICES SAID
THAT WE ADDRESS THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE SO
THAT THEY CAN STAY HOUSE. IT
DOESN'T DO THEM ANY GOOD TO
JUST GIVE THEM A PLACE TO GO
WITHOUT REALLY ADDRESSING THEIR
UNDERLYING NEEDS SIMILARLY FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS FOR ON THE
BRINK OF HOMELESSNESS. THINKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE WRAP OURSELVES
AROUND THEM TO THINK ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS THAT THEY'RE DEALING
WITH. SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
KEEP THEM HOUSE AND SO. MY HOPE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS
AS WE DELIBERATE AS YOU
DELIBERATE THE BUDGET AND WE
ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION WITH
YOU. AT OUR LOCAL PARTNERS IS A
REALLY THINK ABOUT THIS
BALLISTICALLY AND LOOK THIS.
STAFF MOVING FOR. BUT THANK YOU
I. HI A. I THINK ALL THE TIME
ADD BEEN DOING WORK FOR WELL
OVER TWO DE AND I THINK IT
REALLY I FIND IS SOMEWHAT OF A
AN ISSUE OF. AND WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO STAY FOCUSED. FOCUSED
ON THE ISSUE- YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE WATCHED ONE WOMAN IN THIS
PARK THE ENTIRE TEN YEARS I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE FIRST YEAR I TRIED TO OFFER
HER FOOD. I AND SHE WON'T I CAN
YOU CAN APPROACH- AND I'D LIVE
ACROSS FROM THE PARK AND I SEE
HER AND I. SEE THE WOMAN THAT
SPEAKS RUSSIAN- AND TALKS TO
HERSELF ALL NIGHT I MEAN HIGH
LOOK AT THE FACES. AND I
REALIZE I HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
TEN YEARS AND I HAVE GOTTEN
MONEY FOR HOUSING. AND I'VE
WORKED ON HOMELESSNESS AND WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE. AND I A I
THINK IT IS A FAILURE- THAT ALL
OF US SHARE. AND SO I AM WERE
READY TO TRY ANY NEW APPROACH-
AS LONG AS WE'RE GOING TO STICK
TO IT STAY FOCUSED AND MAKE
SURE THOSE RESOURCES ARE GOING
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO ONE MORE
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
THE OUTCOMES. SO I WISH YOU THE
BEST AND IF YOU ARE THE TOP
PERSON I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING TO YOU FURTHER. MORE
EVIL WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOU-
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE I HAVE
WAITED. YEARS FOR PEOPLE TO
MAKE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
OF THIS. AND SO. THIS IS A GOOD
DAY AND I APPRECIATE SO MUCH
YOUR- THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES AND
YOUR DILIGENCE ON THIS. CENTER
FROM. I DON'T USUALLY DO THAT I
APOLOGIZE OUR WELL ACTUALLY I
DON'T BUT- HI MY COLLEAGUES
ALWAYS ASKED ALL THE GREAT
QUESTIONS AND IT'S REALLY GREAT
TO LET THEM GO AND DO THAT
PARTICULAR FOSTER CARE
CONTINUUM OF CARE ALL THESE
ISSUES. ARE THE ARE THE MOST
RELEVANT AND MOST SERIOUS
ISSUES FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS SO- I THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND IF NO ONE ELSE HAS
A COMMENT OR QUESTION. I WILL
TURN TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE AND EVEN
YOUR FAMILY WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF THEY WANTED TO
COME UP AND SPEAK NAY KIA- IT.
LET ME ASK YOU TO COME TO THE
MIGHT GIVE ME YOUR NAME IF YOU
REPRESENT AN ORGANIZATION YOU
WOULD LIKE US TO KNOW ABOUT AND
YOUR- COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. THAT
MY NAME IS DEBBIE TOTH IN A
VERY LOUD AND- I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CHOICE AN
AGING NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
SERVING. SACRAMENTO SOLANO.
CONTRA COSTA AD NAPA COUNTIES
AND I MET- BUT I REPRESENT
MYSELF MY ORGANIZATION- THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION- I SIT
ON THE GOVERNOR'S. THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING STAKEHOLDERS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
RELATED DISORDERS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THOSE ARE MY HATS
SOME OF THEM- AND I MET MARCO
ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND EVERYTHING YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY. I'VE SEEN AND BEEN
A PART OF FOR FIVE YEARS. AND
THERE IS NOBODY MORE IMPRESSIVE
TO BE IN THIS POSITION WHO HAS.
THE PASSION THE DEDICATION THE
EFFICIENCY AND THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT EACH OF US
COME TO THE TABLE AS A HUMAN
BEING AND I. TAKE THIS
APPOINTMENT WILL BE THE BEST
APPOINTMENT YOU EVER MAKE I
BELIEE. THANK YOU. WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M THERMIC DATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND I
DEFINITELY WANT SAY DITTO TO
THE PREVIOUS PERSON MARCO IS AN
AMAZING PARTNER WHEN WORKING
WITH COUNTIES ON HE PROVED THAT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN LAST FALL
WITH THE PS PS SHUTDOWNS AND
COORDINATING HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR THOSE WERE
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
YOUR QUESTION MADAM CHAIR ABOUT
THE HAPPY OUTBREAK AND HOW WE
WORK WITH COUNTIES MARKERS BEEN
WORKING ON THAT- HE ALSO BRINGS
NOT ONLY A HUMANITY AN
INTELLIGENCE TO THE POSITION
BUT ALSO A KEEN INTEREST IN
DATA. AND REALLY SOLVING
PROBLEMS BY USING DATA- NOT
KIND OF SHOOTING IN THE DARK ON
SOME POLICY ISSUES BUT REALLY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
ISSUE IS AND THEN HOW WE CAN
SOLVE IT WE REALLY THINK THAT'S
REFRESHING ANSI SECONDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SENATORS BETSEY
ARMSTRONG WE HAVE THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. DITTO TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FERRIS SAD BUT ALSO
WE HAVE FOUND MARCO. TO BE
WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH VERY
RESPONSIVE WHEN WE COME WITH
ISSUES HE'S VERY QUICK TO. GET
BACK TO US AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I WELCOME
PENSION MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OUT SOUTH UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
MOST RECENT THING WE'VE WORKED
ON IS CORONAVIRUS. UP WITH
MARCO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN AND THAT
CAPACITY AND MANY OTHERS AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. ENSURE
MEMBERS BUT REALLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF YOU TO THE ASPEN
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY WE HAVE
A GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOU AND YOU HAVE EXTENSIVE
KNOWLEDGE OF. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES POLICY AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS APPOINTMENT TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS A RICK ROLLINS
REPRESENT ARC ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL SAN A- SERVING THREE
AND SIXTY THOUSAND AND GROWING-
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES HEARING
CALIFORNIAN THEIR FAMILIES
WE'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF.
WORKING WITH MARCO- SINCE HIS
APPOINTMENT WE- THINK HE'S
SMART WE- REALLY LOOK AT HIS
VISION AND I'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TO. FIRST
THE STATE'S SUSTAINABILITY OF
OUR SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TEN MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT HE AND WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF MARCO'S A
CLATTER OF STYLE WE MET WITH
THEM IS NOT DISSIMILAR TO
CENTER BASIS DESCRIPTION IS
IT'S ALMOST AS IF HE KNEW WHAT
WE WERE GOING TO SAY WHAT WE'RE
COMING IN TO PITCH HIM ON. AND
YET HE TOOK THAT HE LISTENS AND
HE TAKES IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL
HE CHALLENGES US AS AN
ORGANIZATION TO THINK IN A
BROADER SENSE OF HOW EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS CAN'T INTO WHAT HE
DESCRIBED IN HIS OPENING
STATEMENT IS HOW TO CREATE-
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
SO WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT HIS
CONFIRMATION AND WE APPRECIATE
HIS WILLINGNESS TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BY STOCKARD IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS. WE FOUND WORKING
WITH MISTER BEACH ON ISSUES
RELATED TO WORK FORCE PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE
FOUND HIM TO BE VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE. BURKE SENSIBLE
VERY TRANSPARENT. BELIEVE HE'S
GOING TO BE TO BE A WONDERFUL
REPRESENT REPRESENTATIVE OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION. WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR
CONFIRMATION AN APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEAR THAN HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MARCUS APPOINTMENT
TODAY- HE'S BEEN A FABULOUS
ADVOCATE IN TERMS OF LOOK
WANTING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND ENSURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
FORGOTTEN. IN OUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SYSTEM AND IT'S
BEEN EXCITING TO WATCH BECOME A
FATHER DURING THAT TIME AS WE
WORKED ON AND- CREATING THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING INITIATIVE
PROGRAM SO. JUST WANNA SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF HIM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY I ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NONE-
SENATOR ROTH. CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES HI BATES ONLINE
MONNING RALPH RALPH I WILL.
WILK AYE ACTIONS I AND WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A BIT-
FOR SENATOR MINING BUT I
ANTICIPATE YOU'LL HAVE-
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT MISTER BEACH
CONGRATULATIONS. AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES- THAT IS. THE EXTENT
OF OUR MEETING AGAIN I WILL
HAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A BIT-
FOR SENATOR MINING THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR WALK FOR
THE COMPUTER NO NO NO.
FOR
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM ONE BE SENATOR MONNING.
I THANK MONNING AYE FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. AND WE ARE ADJOURNED.